[Music]
he's gone
[Music]
we just watched the season 7 finale of
when calls the heart and if I'm a season
6 ended with Lucas got the dance Nathan
got the glance season 7 on the other
hand Nathan got the hug
Lucas was left with the shrug Oh always
wondering what you're gonna ride with I
want to know your immediate reactions to
when you first saw what was gonna happen
in this season 7 finale the first time I
read it I was like do I get shot the
beginning we were writing this we went
some of the graphs are coming in wasn't
they hadn't fully made up their mind on
what was gonna happen who was gonna get
you know take the bullet so I really
didn't know what was going on so I was
very curious to see how that last minute
who's gonna play out what were you guys
well I thought that Lucas was gonna
shoot Nathan that we get to some kind of
situation where whether it's accidental
or maybe a little bit from purpose
I saw you delivering for that that
script that you're like hey guys take a
look at this I was an idea last night
just roll with it if you want Aaron as
the as the EP do you have a say in the
screenwriting and and the outcomes of
how these episodes although I'm
definitely a part of that creative
process I'm certainly not the final
decision-maker so you know for all of
you Hardy's were tweeting at me about
the mistakes that I'm making no no but I
am I mean I was we had a lot of
conversations about how we wanted this
season to end and you know should Lucas
see this moment or should this moment
happen and how should it happen I think
it's kind of nice that we were able to
flip things from the way we ended last
season six not that it's exactly the
same I like what you went with
you said hug and shrug
I make about the embrace yes won the
race did you say he had the puppeyface
and Kevin you showed us a great
puppeyface at the end of season six that
was my audition for the show that's all
they asks they're like hey can you come
in and look longingly at the camera you
got the back Chris I want to ask you you
know Lucas hustled this season he put in
so much work to respectfully court
Elizabeth so I want to know what was
going through Lucas's mind as he had to
watch Elizabeth embrace Nathan like very
emotionally I feel like Lucas felt
pretty confident by the end you know if
Eve yeah thought he had made some pretty
great strides and that everything was
sort of falling into place the way that
he wanted so I feel like it when he
witnesses that embrace it's sort of um
takes his feet up from under him because
he didn't realize that those ties were
that's strong and yet to make I think he
has to rethink his whole situation okay
and then conversely Kevin for Nathan to
finally get a moment of connection with
Elizabeth what was that like I think
Nathan is overjoyed but at the same time
just under the circumstances I you know
he coming back into the town he is his
mind it's clearly on that he lost you
know a partner
another Mountie and we don't know you
know moving forward maybe this is the
first time that he's ever lost somebody
under his watch
so yeah like the embrace was great and I
mean I think what's proven is that there
is something between Elizabeth but it is
under sad circumstances like I think is
as Nathan was upset with her and up in
the mountain you know they gotta fight
and basically what was fueling that was
that he just didn't
her to get hurt so he'd never see her
again that's what I thought naina was
saying he didn't want to lose her you
know her so he yelled at her he he
exploded on the yell he explode he did
not yell
he might have raised his voice a little
but he was he was scared that he would
never see her I think that's where that
came from to it with Elizabeth bracing
it but she was afraid that you know
she'd never see Nathan again and I think
those feelings will lead to some very
you know that definitely it's gonna grow
and or it may be maybe Nathan will be
able to you know communicate a little
bit better now that I don't know they've
been kind of texts in this way but I
mean look you and I spoke on set in
September and you very playfully and
lovingly said something to the effect of
Nathan needs to learn how to talk to
girls
Nathan is bad at talking to girls well I
need to know and throughout this season
I just kept rooting for him and he just
I don't know for whatever reason he
didn't feel confident enough to ask
Elizabeth out he finally got to see that
happen in the season 7 finale would you
like to get dinner with me when I get
back maybe at their cafe what took so
long
well I think those are questions from
the future that I think it would be
great to dive into why nathan is like
this why either maybe who said it maybe
he lost somebody in the best maybe yeah
what did happen why he is he so
tongue-tied when it comes to women but
especially Elizabeth not so much like
he's not so running away from every girl
in Hope Valley but something with
Elizabeth you know maybe there's a guilt
thing there with it's you know she was
married to a Mountie and maybe he feels
like it's wrong maybe it doesn't I don't
know these are these are questions I
look forward to answering or to dive in
diving deeper in
if the story continued Elizabeth what
were you thinking I was thinking that I
heard Emily and I wasn't just going to
leave her out there I told you I would
get her but he didn't I did with my help
if I hadn't have gotten to her she might
have died
you're both could have died Kevin you
had a great scene with Aaron this season
where you got to be pretty feisty and I
want to know being the close friends
that you are what was it like having a
heated seem like that what was it like
yelling in there
surprisingly easy I don't know it just
kind of came no I think you know it's
just we actually everyone I talked with
that scene and we were fighting to make
it a bit more punch here it's earned um
you know as you know abrasive as Nathan
might have been it he's been penting up
you know these feelings jealousy for
Lucas but also fear that you might have
lost her or his niece as well
fear of losing her but also maybe her
letting him down by going out there and
it just made it more real to me it felt
it felt like yeah this would be the
timeline of this this he should go off
and be alone with his thoughts right now
and realize that he made a mistake and
and personally I have no desire to play
anybody who is perfect or like I think
we should all be I think we tune in to
watch somebody make a mistake you know
try fail and then try again fail you
know fail better try whatever whatever
that's saying so please in the future
just just let me do my job
Aaron what was it like being on the
receiving end of Nathan's heated angry
passion oh I think Elizabeth was just
ready for him to say what he was
actually thinking it's like yeah I mean
I got it buddy you're you're clearly
upset and I don't totally blame you I
mean I understand but can you not be
such a tool about it thank I mean I it
was it was a little harsh and I think it
was played perfectly but for Elizabeth
it was a moment of what is really going
on here but life is too short not to
appreciate the good things when they
happen can you meet me tonight in the
library
[Music]
okay so let's let's flip and talk a
little bit about Lucas and Elizabeth now
Chris reflect a little on this season
and Elizabeth and Lucas's friendship
possibly developing into something more
well I think we've seen in season seven
that that these two characters have a
lot in common and that they they can
challenge each other well and that they
bring positive sides out of each other
out so I think they made some great some
great progress and great strategist is
respecting one another this season and
appreciating one another so I'm looking
forward to seeing what we're what could
come ahead I mean what do you hope
happens next I wouldn't mind having some
more conflict because that's fun to play
with so I would like for things to get
messy before anything gets better and
whatever that means if something messy
can it can happen in in the future that
it has something to do with Lucas's
character and personality and we can
kind of dabble in a little bit of
darkness or mystery or suspicion or
something is that why you're growing out
Thea
yeah yeah I'm basically you're evil
right didn't become Doc Holliday yeah
you'll be prepared yeah and I might even
gently brush your hair as I pass you
your glass and hold your gaze for longer
than normal
and how I think ours very sweet
handles in the library that big date
scene fans lost their marbles I was
screaming at the TV I was like yes Lucas
romance thank you I think that was the
most romance we saw all season like I
almost felt like I was part of something
I shouldn't be watching yeah I mean the
dialogue like the way that that was was
scripted it was just it was a sexy one
calls the heart moment how did it feel
to film something like that
hazardous yeah it was a burn permit for
those I don't think it's fire safety is
a big joke to Lucas Wow something to
even take seriously yes yeah well I mean
you have that many can't first of all he
completely must have cleared Ned Yost
out at the Berkut toilet - yeah but not
the entire staff all the inventory and
then decides to light them all in a room
filled with paper right a wooden room a
wooden room filled with paper Aaron how
did it feel for Elizabeth to finally
show the most I would say like
vulnerability romantically oh you know I
think the whole season Elizabeth has
really been holding her feelings close
she's felt that openness but hasn't
really been willing to put herself out
there and and so this in the season
finale we get to see her really starting
to play with the idea of being ready for
more romance in her life and yeah that
was a particularly sweet scene very very
charming and and maybe even a little
sneaky of Lucas not in a bad way to
frame it that he knows it's not a date
but we can still play make-believe um
yeah
or what it might be like if it was a
date so yeah it was a very very sweet
and charming woman I also personally
really enjoyed that that scene was the
final scene we shot in season seven and
so Aaron and I got to finish
yeah just finish everything off with
would basically toasting a bottle of
bubbles so is a lovely way to finish
this evening Chris was lovely enough to
bring in some very lovely real bubbles
for us to toast with so oh so that was
yeah that's that's the Sabre one right
that he is a birthday yeah which Aaron
gifted me for my birthday and I thank
you for that saber it's actually just
right over here oh now guess I was gonna
ask was you know I think fans really
love how close especially the three of
you are you guys are just always like
laughing and joking with one another
what is it like being such good friends
like you guys are and then having to go
film a romantic scene like that
do you ever crack up in the middle of it
take or do you have conversations before
you go in and film those I mean it's not
like really had to film anything to do
risque actually or you know it's not
really weird and I you know I I don't
think it will be weird we're all
professionals but it is so nice to get
to work with people that I genuinely
like and you know when we were casting
these guys we got to spend very limited
time with them and so it's it's pretty
miraculous that you're both such awesome
guys and you fit into the cast so
seamlessly and if anything I really
think you've just elevated it and we're
all really really happy that you're a
part of the one calls the heart family
and I'm thrilled that I get to call you
guys friends so thank you thank you were
there ever conversations in the writers
room of possibly sneaking a kiss in not
to my knowledge and I would have said
hard part no tell me why it's been a
slow burn with both of these guys and I
I don't think that I don't think it
would have made sense to have a kiss in
this season certainly not before
Elizabeth had kind of made up her mind a
little bit more gosh she can barely call
a date a date and she's very rigid about
normal or just this is
friends and I'll go with you to Union
City but don't get any ideas and I think
she's sort of wanting to encourage
Nathan but when he finally does ask her
out she can't even say yes I mean with
both of these guys it's just this sense
of excitement but trepidation so
everything is moving very slowly okay
well you bring up Nathan did finally ask
Elizabeth out but before she could even
respond the whole gunshot debacle
happened so I want to know Erin do we
have an answer or Elizabeth and Nathan
going to dinner at the cafe I mean I
really we're gonna have to tune in in
season eight okay so our congratulations
in order can we confirm that you guys
are coming back for season eight yes
please congratulate us congratulations
Betty it is music to our ears as fans
because I think I have told you this
before Aaron and I truly believe it I
think the show is in its prime you guys
are doing such incredible storytelling
the acting is phenomenal you guys keep
us hooked every Sunday night just like
waiting for more and more of Andy's
beloved characters what can we expect in
season eight luckily that's that's not
my job I'm not writing it but I I I hope
more of the same and that we'll get to
continue to deepen these relationships
and storylines and I'm also so excited
because I feel like we still have a lot
more stories to tell our cast and crew
are some of my best friends and so I'm
really looking forward to getting to
spend more 16-hour days together or
whatever they are I mean Chris and Kevin
you guys you guys joined the party in
season six what does it mean to know
that you're now going into your third
season with the show well we didn't sink
the ship so that feels pretty good I
think it's amazing be part of something
that that isn't you know moved and touch
so many people it's been like Erin said
coming on to a cast that you just think
you really genuinely like and and and it
really is it's just it doesn't even feel
like work I'm very happy to be going
with this story
how do you feel well I I'm very thankful
and grateful for anybody watching this
who who might think that we have a very
sort of easy job it's not and we never
have security for more than one year at
a time
we'll be picked up for one season and
then we'll have to see so if you can
imagine having a job where every year it
resets and you don't know if you have a
job the next year that can take a mental
toll so for me personally it's just I'm
very grateful to be able to have a job
again this year at some point or me you
know whenever we're able to go but yeah
I'm just very appreciative and on the
other side of that I'm excited because
it's like like Kevin said it doesn't
feel like work I think everybody on this
show gets along very well and so you're
really just going to hang out with your
friends and do something that we all
really love to do you know it's all a
passion of ours and I think that's why
we're in this in this business so yeah
I'm thrilled can I ask how is you know
the ramifications of the corona virus
how will that affect production because
I know you guys typically start like at
the end of summer is that right
that's right hmm I think we're just kind
of taking things one day at a time as as
more and more information is coming to
us so I mean the goal is to get back to
Hope Valley and get back to work as soon
as we can as soon as we safely can but
obviously safety is gonna be the key
word there a lot of companies have have
expressed interest in this and and I am
one of them I don't know if this is
within your control but have you ever
considered doing more than 10 episodes
of season it flies by too quickly and I
feel like just as things start bubbling
up it's like we're here at the finale
and we want more that's something that
you can make happen you've talked about
it um you know we usually stick to a 10
episode season with the two-hour
Christmas movie if that's something
that's important to the fans and our
viewers I would encourage everyone to
reach out to Hallmark and let them know
because you need to hear from the fans
we do i before it absolutely yeah yeah
there was there was talk about it I've
heard the murmurs better onset that yeah
adding a few more episodes I think it's
great
[Music]